an amazing thing took place Wednesday
but I bet you didn't hear much about it
a school resource officer in Illinois
stopped a 19 year old gunman at a high
school saving countless lives when the
suspect started shooting near the school
gym the officer confronted him chased
him shot him I could not be more proud
of the police officer and the way you
responded to the situation where shots
ringing out through the hallways of the
school he charged towards a suspect and
confronted him head-on because of his
heroic actions countless lives were
saved we are forever indebted to him for
his service and his bravery so the
obvious question is why isn't this all
over the news after all someone once
said that news isn't just what happens
it's what doesn't happen the problem is
in this case the media isn't interested
in what doesn't happen lives were saved
thankfully so the story didn't fit the
narrative and the press therefore moved
on to other non happening things like
collusion so obviously it's good news
that this wasn't a big story but it's
also bad news that it isn't a big story
for its own sake because in this non
news story truth is revealed that one
can save lives by actually protecting
people for the duration of a gun attack
is always dictated by the arrival of a
second gun and this incident is no
exception
look up the unpublished CDC report that
indicates nearly 2.5 million defensive
uses of guns a year didn't hear about
that either I did say it was unpublished
I wonder why it's the way the press uses
silenced selectively to create only one
story angle that carries the seal of
media approval which is why I did this
monologue in the first place so someone
might hear it and you know the name of
Mark Dallas so katie mark Dallas was the
officer who I just find an interesting
the media is interested in gun and gun
stories except for these kinds yeah well
they're not interested in where guns
save lives and are used to put on
somebody that in fact is trying to do
harm so I like the way you ends about
two and you're like more toss because
that that's important to know the names
the individual that actually committed
you know a heroic act and saved lives
and that's the whole point when we talk
about schools and gun-free zones and
things
like that that are very very vulnerable
there soft targets think about it over
and over again like I said I've
responded to the scenes of the crime and
I was in the officer-involved shooting
team anytime there was a discharge of a
weapon or a shooting like that and the
police had to go out on it you see what
happens and you go to the movie theater
and you go to the school and you go to
these places you say if only someone had
been armed there to be able to do
something and act decisively lives could
be saved so you know weapons are used in
many instances and in wars to create
peace ultimately data the left often
uses every story as some kind of
political tool this is this is something
that says there's an argument for more
guns in schools but you don't really
hear that well part of the reason is
because it works like the process that
was in place for that school district
worked and so if a policy works you
often don't write about it but I also
think that it's in some ways what it
could do what you're saying which is
remember when Rahm Emmanuel said you
never let an opportunity to waste so I
think that this is actually true for on
the other side which is that if you're a
local school district and you're worried
about the possibility of a shooter in
your school having an armed resource
officer could actually be your answer
yeah Jesse should the officer not been
there with a gun should it have been a
gun-free zone exact opposite of what the
officer did in parkland remember he
hidden coward and waited outside this
one followed protocol and directly
addressed and then neutralized the
shooter but your point is exactly right
news isn't necessarily about what you
cover it's about what you don't cover
and your asteroid analogy rings true
here
they don't always cover good economic
news for the Trump administration they
don't cover news that might benefit the
NRA right narrative and that's fine
every outlet has to make their own
editorial decision about what they do or
don't cover but when 90% of the media is
liberal and 10% isn't there's a lot of
impact about what that 90% does not
cover and it does a disservice to the
readers and the viewers who aren't fully
informed before they can make a decision
or have an opinion while I'm sure my
monologue changed your mind completely
hearts and you know it felt to me like
someone had a gun pointed at oh you know
what you felt that before I thing is you
what's interesting to me is not that it
doesn't get covered cuz you're right I
think it's like you know the famous
saying we don't cover safe landings at
national air right so that's not
typically what's gets covered but you
make it into a policy argument about
whether or not guns should be in schools
in their classrooms and all over and
that's where I think I disengaged be
nice to my mind I look at stolen - Jesse
mentioned and there was an armed guard
I look at Columbine I look at Virginia
Tech I look at the pulse nightclub there
were armed guards at all of these mass
shootings did it stop them no and then
you look and you say well let's ask the
people involved let's get away from a
bunch of TV people let's ask the
teachers in these schools they think
that there should they should have guns
that they should be armed guards no what
about the parents parents love kids I
think we'd all agree that the parents
that no parents say they don't want
these guns in their schools maybe
because they know when guns are around
more accidents actually more fatale I
gotta lose that yeah I gotta move on
anyway more guns less crime the CDC
report 2.5 defensive use of guns so
that's that's too